I spent some time yesterday talking about how
the reflexive reaction from the Republicans in
charge of the state of Texas to the power
outages that are happening tragically
in the wake of a storm and cold weather
were blamed on anything on the left that
Republicans could come up with. We talked
about them blaming the Green New Deal, which,
of course, hasn't happened. We talked about
them blaming wind turbines, which, of course,
represent just a small fraction of the energy
generation in Texas. And the truth is, as Philip
Bump writes in The Washington Post and a really
good article that I encourage you to check out,
it has been extraordinarily misleading what
Republicans have done when it comes to pointing
fingers and placing blame in the state of Texas
for what is going on. Of course, anybody talking
about the Green New Deal is ignoring or misleading
in the sense that none of what Texas decided to do
with their power grid has anything to do with
the green green new deal other than the fact
that they've done a little bit of wind power, OK,
and a little bit of solar power. But the reality
is that that represents a very small percentage
of Texases power generation. And the truth about
what's going on in Texas is a combination of
Republicans who have opted in order to avoid
what they call federal regulation of their energy
markets, have their own power grid. Whereas just
about I mean, I don't want to go hyperbolic,
but almost every other part of the world
has a broader, more interconnected power grid than
just one state. The way Texas has that puts Texas
at significant risk in exactly situations like
this. But it's not just that. It's also that
they had a decade to deal with exactly the issue
they're having now. As we talked about yesterday,
Texas had a similar power outage situation.
In 2011, a report was done.
Tons of money was spent on figuring out what
happened and how do you prevent it from happening
again. And they figured out how to prevent it from
happening again. And it includes the winterization
of wind turbines, but more importantly, of
instruments at natural gas, coal and nuclear power
plants, which are the majority of Texas energy.
And they didn't do it. They they opted not to
do that. Other states that have wind power and
other types of power and it gets cold places
like Montana and Wyoming and others, they've
done the winterization. So when it gets cold,
the wind turbines work. Everything works fine. OK,
so this is an example of a Republican stronghold
blaming a problem. They in some cases, it's
caused, in some cases it's failed to deal with
on Democrats or the left or progressivism or
climate science or whatever the case may be.
And this is a trend. This is something that
they have been doing on the right for a very
long time. The right does tax cuts and the
tax cuts rather than helping the economy
don't help the economy because they give the tax
cuts to the rich and trickle down doesn't actually
work. And somehow they blame Democrats. They'll
do tax cuts for the rich and say, this is going
to be great. It's not. And then they say, oh,
well, the problem is Democratic social programs,
the tax cuts for the rich would have worked
were it not for the democratic social programs.
The housing disaster in 2008, which of
course was the result of under regulation
of mortgages and of derivatives from mortgages,
including the packaging up of mortgages and
selling them. We've talked about that really.
It's a problem of under regulation for a very
long time, primarily under George W. Bush
or most acutely under George W. Bush. They
said it's a cop, you know, take your pick.
The list of things they blamed is very,
very long. But some combination of Democratic
policy in cities that created a problem with
housing prices. And, you know, the problem was
on deregulation led by Republicans dating back to
the sort of ideology of Reagan in the 1980s, the
deregulation of the energy industry more broadly.
That's part of what we're seeing in Texas. But but
not only that has not been good for states that
have adopted it as states have deregulated energy
under the idea of we want to give people choice
and we want more competition and players in the
market, everything from scams to exploding prices
have taken place. And by the way, not with any
increased reliability when it comes to energy,
but they blame it. On the left, Kansas, a very
much cautionary tale. Republicans, including
the governor there, Sam Brownback, bankrupting
Kansas, going all in on trickle down economics
and tax cuts for the rich and whatever else,
completely bankrupting Kansas, failing to grow
the business base and the revenue base and blaming
Democrats Inco. Currently, they are now blaming
covid deaths and the fact that although covid
deaths are I mean, listen to the numbers, covid
deaths are down 37 percent from their peak a month
ago. They are blaming covid deaths, which they
didn't even seem to care about when Donald Trump
was president, 40 percent of which were avoidable.
And Joe Biden already, despite Donald Trump
failing to control it for nearly a full year.
Many of these stories in some way are about
either deregulation or when it comes to covid,
not enough federal government involvement,
but they continue to create these disasters,
blame it on Democrats, even though they
are the ones in power, and also blame it
on the ideology that is the opposite of what they
want, when really they should be looking at their
policies of getting government, quote, out
of people's lives, deregulation and so on.
If they're so so the pattern is if they're in
power and there is a disaster, they blame it on
Democrats because Democrats somehow prevented
them from doing what they really wanted to do
or did something that played as a counterweight
to what they did. If Republicans aren't in power,
they'll just say Democrats are in power. So it's
their fault, even if their obstructionism is
actually what caused the problem, sort of
like spoiled children, no accountability,
no integrity, no personal responsibility.
They take credit for everything and
responsibility for nothing, much like Donald
Trump. I mean, it's Donald Trump took that
idea that we've seen Republicans put into place
over the last forty five forty years and just
exploded it to the hundred and ten percentile.
And unfortunately, it doesn't seem like things
are super quickly going to get any better
in Texas. I want to talk about that next.